[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit kaiser
berichte und claus kleber
guten abend der lauf der welt unterbrach
die sommerpause des bundestages
700 + abgeordnete wurden nach berlin
gerufen für eine sondersitzung über
gleich drei katastrophen die pandemie
die fluten an a und erft und das
wichtigste und dringendste von allen der
kollaps der afghanistan politik man
könnte die hilflosigkeit der westlichen
allianz inklusive berlin dabei als
vierte katastrophe mitzählen die
kanzlerin hat er einiges zu erklären
andreas künast hat das verfolgt und
danach sprechen wir mit der
verteidigungsministerin
es geht um die leben von tausenden
menschen es geht um die schuld moral und
um merkel
als schwärzesten punkt in ihrer
16-jährigen kanzlerschaft wird die
opposition heute in afghanistan rückzug
bezeichnen als desaster katastrophe
unverantwortlichkeit merkel verteidigt
sich aber entschuldigt sich nicht alle
die gesamte internationale koalition
habe die geschwindigkeit des
zusammenbruchs unterschätzt hätte
deutschland die mitarbeiter von
hilfsorganisationen
bereits im frühjahr abgezogen
[Applaus]
als vorausschauende vorsicht gewürdigt
andere dagegen als eine haltung
abgelehnt mit der die menschen in
afghanistan im stich gelassen und ihrem
schicksal überlassen werden hinterher im
nachhinein präzise analysen und
bewertungen zu machen das ist nicht
wirklich kompliziert so lange wie
möglich soll die evakuierung fortgesetzt
werden sagte merkel und so viel wie
möglich vom erreichten bewahrt darüber
muss die internationale gemeinschaft
auch mit den taliban sprechen und
kommuniziere unkonditionierte
verabredungen allerdings kann und darf
es nicht geben die kritik der opposition
ist vernichtend die afg greift den
einsatz grundsätzlich an
geschlechtergerechtigkeit in die
muslimische welt zu tragen mussten
deutsche männer dort ihr leben lassen
wie viele afghanische frauen in höchsten
ämtern oder mädchen in schulen wiegen
eigentlich einen deutschen quoten
soldaten auch die debatte ist heftig
teils unversöhnlicher linke und grüne
werfen der regierung politisches und
moralisches versagen vor sie haben
politisch in den letzten wochen
entschieden wo man handeln musste das
innenpolitische motive höher gewertet
werden als unsere deutsche
außenpolitische verantwortung
das bier wird meint der regierung sei
wichtiger gewesen weiter abschieben zu
können die spd jetzt zurück die
heuchelei wird erst dann deutlich wenn
man sie dass sie bis zum letzten
augenblick bis zur letzten stunde in den
regierungen vertreten gewesen waren die
menschen nach afghanistan abstimmen
wollten und das werde ich ihnen nicht
vergessen als konsequenz aus dem rückzug
debakel schlagen cdu und fdp einen
nationalen sicherheitsrat vor
denn die letzten tage und wochen haben
den eindruck organisierter
unverantwortlichkeit verstärkt und das
muss folge für die sicherheitspolitik
unseres landes haben dermaßen
herr seehofer
die letzten wochen sind unentschuldbar
die folgen ihrer fehler gefährden
menschenleben
dann erteilt der bundestag der
bundeswehr rückwirkend ein afghanistan
mandat für das letzte mal das schlimmste
mal
es steht ein schlimmer augenblick bevor
noch längst nicht alle die sich schutz
versprechen sind entkommen und dann wird
ein deutscher soldat die letzte tür des
letzten flugzeugs in kabul schließen und
zurück bleiben menschen die sich auf
deutschland verlassen haben und dann
angewiesen sind auf gnade der taliban
guten abend frau verteidigungsministerin
wie viele tage sind das noch oder sind
das nur stunden das zeitfenster für die
evakuierungs möglichkeiten schließt sich
es wird kleiner ist jedoch deshalb
kleiner weil die bedrohungslage sehr
konkret mit blick auf terroristische
anschläge auf die die evakuiert werden
sollen aber auch auf die soldatinnen
soldaten größer wird wie genau und wie
groß dieses fenster ist darüber möchte
ich nicht spekulieren weil es auch die
arbeit die immer noch unvermindert
weiter geht um so viele menschen wie
möglich auf die flieger zu bekommen
weiter erschwert und die soldaten vor
ort haben es schon mit einer sehr sehr
schweren situation zu tun schwer ist
auch die situation der ministerin die
das zu verantworten hat sie haben in den
letzten tagen deutlich gemacht dass sie
bereit sind verantwortung zu übernehmen
aber nicht in diesem moment wo das alles
jetzt spitz auf knopf steht wenn dieser
rückzug abgeschlossen ist ist dann der
zeitpunkt gekommen für eine
rücktrittserklärung
zuerst immer geht es jetzt um die phase
eines einsatzes die am schwierigsten ist
die am gefährlichsten ist die am
sensibelsten ist für alle und deswegen
sind wir alle im
verteidigungsministerium in der
bundeswehr völlig darauf konzentriert so
viele menschen wie möglich bis zum
schluss raus zu holen und unsere männer
und frauen gesund und sicher wieder
zurückzuholen danach werden wir
sicherlich diesen einsatz diese
evakuierungs mission eine der größten in
unserer geschichte wenn ich die größte
sie lancieren und ich habe gesagt was
ich selbst für mich zu überlegen habe
und werde dann sicherlich auch zu den
entsprechenden schlüssen kommen auch da
sprechen wir jetzt zwangsläufig über nur
tage
auch das ist eine frage die ich mir
stellen werde wenn ich selbst
gelegenheit habe auch zur ruhe zu kommen
jetzt im moment ist mein platz auch als
inhaberin der befehls und kommandogewalt
genau dort an diesem einsatz mitzuhelfen
dass alles zur verfügung steht damit wir
viele menschen noch aus kabul
herausnehmen können und wie gesagt vor
allen dingen dafür sorgen können dass
unsere soldatinnen soldaten sicher
wieder nach hause kommen das ist die
höchste priorität
sie haben recht bleiben wir bei der
gegenwärtigen situation da wird wie
selbstverständlich gesagt dass wenn die
amerikaner raus gehen wir die deutschen
auch raus zu gehen haben warum ist das
so selbstverständlich
berger die bundeswehr oder die
europäischen truppen auf sich gestellt
auch etwas leisten es geht ja nicht um
einen riesigen feldzug es geht um die
absicherung eines flughafens die die
amerikaner im moment mit 5000 mann
bewerkstelligen warum ist aus
selbstverständlich außerhalb der
reichweite europas und deutschland die
amerikaner haben zurzeit über 6000 mann
am boden sie werden unterstützt von
großbritannien sie werden auch mit
robusten kräften unterstützt von uns sie
haben ein unglaubliches equipment eine
unglaubliche ausrüstung in der luft auf
dem boden dinge über die wir in der
masse auch nicht verfügen im übrigen
auch nicht die briten ob die haben
gestern erklärt dass sie nicht in der
lage sind einen flughafen inmitten einer
feindlichen umgebung alleine zu halten
deswegen hängt im moment die sicherheit
auch unsere soldatinnen soldaten vor
allen dingen von der unterstützung der
amerikaner ab das was wir in kabul
leisten ist eine kraftanstrengung von
sehr sehr vielen staaten wir
unterstützen die kleineren wir arbeiten
zusammen mit den amerikanern bis hin zur
evakuierung
maßnahmen die wir getroffen haben unter
einsatz von hubschraubern also das
greift ineinander
aber die frage die sich über diesen
einsatz hinaus stellen wird ist in der
tat wie selbstständig können wir
eigentlich in der hatte und als europäer
ohne die amerikaner agieren wenn man das
für sich will wenn man das beantworten
will dann muss man dafür aber auch
konkret den preis bezahlen etwa in form
von haushaltsmitteln in form von
ausstattung in form von mehr personal
sie können als verteidigungsministerin
in dieser situation nicht sagen ich weiß
nicht was die haltung dazu ist ist es in
diesem wahljahr die position der union
dass die deutsche militärische
kampffähigkeit deutlich gesteigert
werden muss zum beispiel in der nächsten
legislaturperiode das hat nichts mit
diesem wahljahr oder mit diesem
wahlkampf zu tun das ist etwas was ich
schon seit meinem amtsantritt immer
wieder gesagt habe
deutschland ist ein großes und starkes
land von deutschland wird auch erwartet
dass es sich in den bündnissen ein
bündnis wie die nato auf gegenseitigkeit
entsprechend einbringen das haben wir
jetzt gerade getan mit material mit
robusten kräften und wenn wir uns nicht
abhängig machen wollen von anderen von
der hilfe anderer wenn wir selbst
eigenständiger agieren wollen dann
müssen wir uns entsprechend aufstellen
das bedeutet wir müssen die fähigkeit
haben zu agieren das bedeutet politisch
aber auch dass wir den willen haben zum
beispiel auch in robuste einsätze zu
gehen dass es dann die debatte die wir
im parlament zu führen haben denn die
bundeswehr ist eine parlamentsarmee und
ist zunächst einmal eine demokratie
armee das heißt das müsste jetzt im
wahlkampf eigentlich ein thema sein mit
einer klaren position der
verteidigungsministerin sie regen nur im
moment an der debatte nein die
verteidigungsministerin ich selbst habe
dazu eine vollkommene klare auffassung
ich habe das immer besteht aber nicht um
partei und programm der union oder gehen
das zu finden sich auch im wahlprogramm
der cdu wieder und sie haben vollkommen
recht bei dieser bundestagswahl geht es
um eine richtungsentscheidung
es geht darum ob die bundeswehr in
dieser einsätze bestmöglich geschützt
geht ob sie in dieser einsätze geschickt
wird auch mit ihren spezialkräften oder
es geht darum ob diejenigen in zukunft
verantwortung tragen die das bisher
immer mit verhindern wollten oder
verhindert also insofern eine sehr
grundsätzliche richtungsentscheidung
auch und gerade in der
verteidigungspolitik eine kurze frage
noch das parlament und die regierung
haben sich ja zuletzt durchgerungen dass
es einen großen zapfenstreich geben soll
für die soldaten die in afghanistan
gedient haben werden sie gewährleisten
dass das auch jetzt nach diesem debakel
am ende noch stattfindet auf jeden fall
denn das ist heute im bundestag auch
deutlich geworden es gab und es gibt
niemanden der gesagt hätte die
bundeswehr hat ihre aufträge die sie vom
parlament erhalten hat in afghanistan
nicht erfüllt dort sind männer und
frauen gestorben wenn er gestorben in
afghanistan für diesen einsatz und
deswegen ist es gerechtfertigt dass in
einem ordentlichen abschluss appell auch
zu begehen der toten zu gedenken und
auch einen großen stab zapfenstreich
durchzuführen aber ganz sicherlich nicht
mehr vor dem wahltermin
dankeschön frau ministerin bitteschön
es hieß ja wir gehen gemeinsam rein vor
20 jahren und wir gehen auch gemeinsam
wieder raus das wurde eingehalten das
bedeute aber eigentlich nur dass wenn
die usa gehen die anderen sich nicht
halten können also auch gehen müssen joe
biden hat für die usa und damit für alle
entschieden den weg zu ende zu gehen dem
barack obama schon einschlagen wollte
und den donald trump dann eingeschlagen
hat beiden setzt damit den ruf der usa
als verlässlicher partner aufs spiel
vielleicht gibt er ihnen sogar auf
darauf gibt es auch in den usa nicht nur
beifall berichtet claudia bates aus
washington
dass die taliban jetzt alles über rennen
und das ganze land übernehmen ist höchst
unwahrscheinlich
diese grundlegende fehleinschätzung halt
nach ab dann nahm das chaos seinen lauf
in afghanistan die us-regierung dachte
sie hätte zeit als die schon knapp war
hat das afghanische militär überschätzt
die taliban unterschätzt und jetzt
wollen alle nur noch weg hier doch eine
verlängerung des evakuierungseinsatz das
lehnt beiden ab ein akutes risiko von
terroranschlägen am flughafen in kabul
die sicherheitslage erzwinge ein
schnelles ende
aber die taliban sagten auch schlicht
nein zu einer verlängerung und sie haben
hier jetzt das sagen und die usa und
ihre verbündeten sind auf ihre
kooperation angewiesen um so viele
menschen wie möglich aus zu fliegen
biden habe sich dem terror gebeugt sagen
kritiker der präsident schickte seinen
cia direktor william burns um direkt mit
der taliban-führung zu sprechen
bill burns als unterhändler zu haben der
afghanistan sehr gut kennt ist ein
ermutigendes zeichen dass sie vorangehen
sie tun alles was möglich ist trotz der
vorherigen fehleinschätzungen um über
die nächsten tage sicherzustellen dass
dies so reibungslos und sicher klappt
wie möglich
doch burns hatte nicht viel anzubieten
so heißt es aus verteidigungskreisen
einen funktionierenden sauberen
flughafen könne man über geben dafür
bitte vier tage verlängerung die taliban
sagten nein haben aber keineswegs alle
zügel in der hand
die taliban bewegen sich auf einem
schmalen grat weil sie zwar wissen wie
sie im land herrschen sollen aber auch
wissen dass sie dafür geld aus dem
westen brauchen deshalb müssen sie jetzt
anders erscheinen als vor 20 jahren ich
glaube nur nicht dass sie das lang
aufrechterhalten können
republikanische und demokratische
abgeordnete forderten dass die deadline
verschoben wird auch wenn es gefährlich
ist harsche kritik an beiden
ich nenne das ein komplettes desaster
von epischem ausmaß
es wird ein makel auf dieser
präsidentschaft sein besonders nach der
jetzigen entscheidung nicht zu
verlängern hat der präsident blut an
seinen händen
er der sehr auf seinen ruf als
sympathischer politiker bedacht ist
nimmt dies in kauf er will das problem
afghanistan hinter sich lassen sich
anderen herausforderungen zuwenden und
den makel hofft er abschütteln zu können
durch erfolge über decken zu können doch
alleingänge und fehleinschätzungen haben
seine glaubwürdigkeit und das vertrauen
in sein urteilsvermögen stark
angeschlagen
darüber was die bedrückenden nachrichten
aus kabul für soldatinnen und soldaten
bedeuten die dort im ersatz war spricht
da sagte mir im update mit dem
vorsitzenden des bundeswehrverbandes
gegen 0.40 und nun nachrichten von
kaiser bericht mit einer weiteren
wichtigen entscheidungen im bundestag
die abgeordneten stimmten für eine
verlängerung der epidemischen lage von
nationaler tragweite vorerst bis zum 30
november damit haben die länder
weiterhin eine rechtsgrundlage für die
korona maßnahmen und auch der bund kann
ohne zustimmung des bundesrates
bestimmte verordnungen erlassen ohne die
verlängerung wäre die epidemische
notlage ende september ausgelaufen
hintergrund sind die steigenden
infektionszahlen das robert koch
institut meldet 11.500 61 neue fälle
innerhalb von 24 stunden das in
3237 mehr als vergangenen mittwoch
außerdem wurden binnen eines tages 39
todesfälle registriert
die sieben tage incidents liegt jetzt
bei 61,3
nach der stuttgarter krawallnacht im
vergangenen sommer hatte die polizei
rund 140 tatverdächtiger ausgemacht nun
gab sie bekannt dass die hälfte von
ihnen von sogenannten super recken
eisern identifiziert wurden also
menschen die besonders gut gesichter
wiedererkennen im juni 2020 hatten
vorwiegend jugendliche in der
stuttgarter innenstadt gewütet auslöser
war eine drogenkontrolle bei den
krawallen wurden auch polizisten bedroht
und verletzt die randalierer verwüsteten
außerdem zahlreiche schaufenster und
plünderten geschäfte
die bundesregierung will einen
internationalen klima club gründen er
sei offen für alle staaten die im kampf
gegen die erderwärmung vorangehen wollen
so vizekanzler scholz ziel sei es
gemeinsame standards zu setzen um
nachteile für die unternehmen zu
vermeiden derzeit hätten starten mit
geringen standards einen vorteil der
klimawandel lasse sich weder national
noch europäisch bewältigen deshalb sei
es entscheidend ob auch china und die
usa mitziehen
die flutkatastrophe von mitte juli hat
finanziell gesehen deutlich größere
schäden verursacht als bisher angenommen
inzwischen geht der gesamtverband der
deutschen versicherungswirtschaft von
rund sieben milliarden euro aus dabei
entfallen sechseinhalb milliarden auf
hohen gebäude hausrat und betriebe der
rest auf fahrzeuge insgesamt zähle man
eine viertelmillion schadenfälle die
tatsächlichen schäden seien noch weit
höher da viele häuser nicht versichert
waren
sieben milliarden zahlen die
versicherungen das ist eine menge geld
und dabei kommen die wirklich großen
beträge nicht mal von den versicherungen
sondern mit hilfszahlungen und
investitionen von bund und ländern 30
milliarden euro hat der bundestag heute
beschlossen und es eilt herbst und
winter kommen bald viele familien haben
das dach über dem kopf verloren wasser
heizung straßenanschluss und dabei hat
die natur gezeigt dass man nicht einfach
dasselbe wieder aufbauen kann was vorher
stand und wo es stand nun müssen
schwierige entscheidungen fallen in
familien und den ortschaften die noch
nicht verkraften können was über sie und
ihr leben gekommen ist susanne gelhard
berichtet aus dem tal der
professor schrott kennt das ahrtal als
privatmann von wanderungen jetzt kommt
er als katastrophenforscher mit seinen
studierenden nach bernau um die ursachen
des katastrophalen hochwassers zu
erkunden
man muss sich natürlich genau überlegen
wo im aartal darf in zukunft gesiedelt
werden aber das heißt natürlich auch was
müssen wir generell tun um unsere
frühwarnsysteme zu verbessern sie sind
den oberlauf der abgefahren dort könnte
man aus dem hilfsfonds relativ
kostengünstig ausweichflächen schaffen
meint professor schrott und so dem
wasser künftig seine kraft nehmen
währenddessen sind die einwohner von
bernau mit wiederaufbau beschäftigt das
dorf ist zu 90 prozent zerstört hier
sind viele auf finanzielle hilfe
angewiesen bleiben oder gehen das
überlegen sie hier viele erinnerungen
jetzt weg wenn man dann sagt das ganze
haus verkaufen und wegziehen man lebt ja
hier man kennt die leute bis heimat da
das level da die sind gefüllt und das
muss aufrechterhalten werden da das
einfach da es hier drin im herz aber es
gibt auch andere die dann sagen nein wir
möchten dass in unserem leben nicht noch
einmal mitmachen und kehren dörner den
rücken straßen schienen brücken auch der
aufbau der infrastruktur soll zum teil
aus dem hilfsfonds gestemmt werden
allein die beseitigung von müll schlamm
und schutt hat in rheinland pfalz bisher
weit über eine halbe milliarde euro
gekostet
die gasleitungen im aartal sind komplett
zerstört tausende ohne heizung jetzt
müssen tiefere und stabilere leitungen
unter der a verlegt werden
das ausmaß der schäden ist wirklich
gewaltig im ahrtal wir reden hier über
133 kilometer gasleitungen zerstört
wurden das betrifft etwa 8000 haushalte
also netzanschlüsse die auch durchaus
von mehreren haushalt natürlich genutzt
werden können milliarden hilfen für den
wiederaufbau im hochwassergebiet die
bürgermeisterinnen und bürgermeister im
aartal fordern dafür einen masterplan
und übergreifende koordination wir
müssen ja ganz neu anfangen und da kann
nicht in meinen augen jede gemeinde oder
jede gebietskörperschaft nur an sich
denken sondern wir müssen eigentlich das
ganze als gesamtes sehen wenn man muss
aus den fehlern lernen und das ahrtal in
der zukunft glaube ich könnte ein
pilotprojekt sein wie man idealerweise
vorsorgende maßnahmen in der fläche
umsetzt um das ahrtal wieder lebens und
liebenswert zu machen neben dem
hilfsfonds sind nun vor allem kluge
konzepte nötig meint professor schrott
und da seien alle gemeinsam gefragt
alle gemeinsam sollte auch für die
korona pandemie gelten denn das langsame
impf tempo in ärmeren ländern könnte die
weltwirtschaft millionen kosten zu
diesem ergebnis kommt eine studie im
auftrag des wirtschaftsmagazins
economist demnach könnten sich die
verluste in den kommenden drei jahren
auf knapp zwei billionen euro belaufen
vor allem in den entwicklungs- und
schwellenländern dadurch werde sich hier
anschluss an die weiter entwickelten
länder weiter verzögern die stimmung der
deutschen wirtschaft hat sich im august
deutlich stärker eingetrübt als erwartet
das zeigt der ifo geschäftsklimaindex
zum einen machen den unternehmen
lieferengpässe zu schaffen deshalb
wollen viele nun ihre preise erhöhen zum
anderen sorgen sich viele wegen der
steigenden corona zahlen besonders im
gastgewerbe und tourismus
zu den gewinnern der pandemie gehört die
computerspielbranche schließlich musste
man sich im locker und irgendwie
beschäftigen was da gerade state of the
art ist zeigt dir der weltgrösste die
die welt größte computerspielmesse die
gamescom hat am abend in köln begonnen
oder besser gesagt im internet denn sie
findet virtuell statt aber wenn damit
jemand gut zurecht kommt dann doch
sicherlich die gamer frank bethmann oder
ja ganz sicher und der veranstalter die
koelnmesse versucht aus der not eine
tugend zu machen wie digital eben noch
mehr menschen erreichen als zuletzt ein
millionenpublikum mit einem milliarden
markt dahinter in deutschland spielt
inzwischen die hälfte der bevölkerung
zumindest gelegentlich am computer
zuwachs gibt es nicht nur in allen
altersgruppen sondern auch beim umsatz
der allein im ersten halbjahr erneut auf
jetzt 4,6 milliarden euro angewachsen
ist trotz aller bedenken computerspiele
seien gefährlich würden abhängig machen
ist deutschland inzwischen der größte
markt in europa heimische unternehmen
jedoch profitieren von diesem boom kaum
deutschland leide unter erheblichen
standortnachteil klagen die
verbandsverantwortlichen nicht zuletzt
das fehlende flächendeckende internet
und der mangel an fachkräften schrecken
firmengründer ab viel bessere
voraussetzungen finden die entwickler
von spielen in den usa und kanada die
den zukunftsmarkt gaming viel früher
erkannt und gefördert haben hierzulande
hat man lange unterschätzt welches job
potenzial in der branche steckt
inzwischen fördert auch die
bundesregierung das gaming mit millionen
und ersten erfolgen die anzahl von
firmen die computerspiele entwickeln und
veröffentlichen ist binnen jahresfrist
in deutschland um 20 prozent gestiegen
taxis ohne fahrer daran arbeitet unter
anderem die google schwester jamie nach
einer zwölfjährigen testphase fahren
jetzt die ersten wagen in san francisco
bei dem pilotprojekt können sich
interessierte als fahrgast bewerben und
dann vollautomatisch kutschieren lassen
bis 2022 wert auf dem beifahrersitz aber
noch ein sicherheitsfahrer mit
kurz noch der blick auf die lottozahlen
wie immer ohne gewähr
6 9 11 12 24 33 super 27 weiter
gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de und in zdf
text auf seite 55 7
es kommt in die kinos sein spielfilm der
obersten liga mit anthony hopkins
die handlung spielt in einem abenteuer
auf das sich viele familien in ihrem
realen leben einlassen der not
gehorchend oder der liebe erwachsene
menschen ziehen wieder unter einem dach
mit den eltern beide generationen geben
ihre unabhängigkeit 'nen auf schon dass
es ein spannungsfeld und da fängt gerade
erst an lässt ein miterleben wie der
alte vater seinen sinnen immer weniger
trauen kann wie demenz realität und
waren sich in seinem kopf vermengen da
spielt sich doch ein verbrechen ab oder
doch nicht der film treibt auch die
zuschauer immer tiefer unentrinnbar in
den strudel der zweifel sabine schulz
empfiehlt einen atemberaubend
verwirrenden film mit einem das sieht
man schon in den ausschnitten
großartigen anthony hopkins
wann sind sie geboren freitag 31
dezember 1937 sie leben zur zeit mit
ihrer tochter zusammen richtig ja in
meiner wohnung
kümmert sich um ihren vater und dafür
ist sie bei ihm eingezogen zusammen mit
paul ihrem mann ich will dir helfen
helfen wobei es ist alles bestens
der resolute alte herr jedoch besteht
auf seine eigenständigkeit
doch gegend etwas stimmt hier nicht
wie ein krimi entführt uns dieser film
in ein labyrinth aus rätseln und
widersprüchen wer ist der fremde mann im
wohnzimmer ein eindringling
was tun sie
was uns in meiner wohnung
ich wohne hier
dieser film ist wie eine art basel ich
wollte dass der zuschauer aktiv wird und
versucht das bild zusammenzufügen das
rätsel zu knacken noch immer fehlt ein
wichtiges puzzlestück ich lade den
zuschauer ein zu erleben wie es ist die
orientierung zu verlieren das vertrauen
in die eigene wahrnehmung den bezug zur
realität
seltsame dinge passieren um uns herum
[Musik]
ich bin hier
realitätsverlust und klare momente
hilflosigkeit da sehen boshaftigkeit
drei pflegerinnen hat er schon vertraut
dann wieder plötzliche charmeoffensive
anthony hopkins verkörpert grandios ein
wechselbad der geistes und
gemütszustände
ich hoffe der film macht dem zuschauer
bewusst wie kostbar und zerbrechlich das
leben ist und dass wir aufeinander
achtgeben und vor allem nicht so schnell
urteilen sollten
ich denke der film eröffnet einen
anderen blick auf demenz und auf das
hohe alter
es geht auch um das moralische dilemma
der tochter intensiv dargestellt von
olivia colman zwischen sorge und
überforderung kann ich ihnen eine
vorgestellt
wie lange haben sie noch vorher
rumzuhängen und das leben ihrer tochter
zu ruinieren
ein starkes kammerspiel unsentimental
und doch berührend
wir müssen uns eine andere lösung
einfallen lassen und ich würde meine
wohnung nicht verlassen ich will nicht
verlassen
doch in welcher wohnung sieht wir
überhaupt raum zeit und handlung sprünge
erinnerungsfetzen und brüche lassen und
spüren was es heißt die kontrolle über
geist und leben zu verlieren
am ende werden wir alles verstehen
besser verstehen der diesem film gelingt
ein kunststück er verwirrt unsere sinne
und schärft unser bewusstsein
[Musik]
was dann die führung
ab morgen in den kinos und das war es
von uns bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend das tief nick hat seine kalt
falls zu uns geschickt und die zieht
jetzt im laufe der nächsten 24 stunden
weiter nach süden sie sehen aber auch
ganz schön dass diese regenwolken die
richtung westen mehr und mehr
auseinander fleddern und das hängt
zusammen mit dem hochkar ja da wird
einfach ein bisschen freuen sich ja
sonst aber bleiben wir in dieser
nordwestströmung und die käufer und die
bringt heute nacht eben regen und um die
mittelgebirge aber auch in berlin
dahinter lockern die wolken auf und hier
in süddeutschland da verschwindet der
klaren sternenhimmel mehr und mehr
hinter wolken deswegen wird die kommende
nacht auch nicht ganz so kalt wie die
vergangene unser warten einstellige
temperaturen von acht oder sieben grad
am alpenrand oder auch im südwesten
sonst geht's auf 15 bis 10 grad runter
und morgen über tag bleibt es doch für
die meisten recht kühl mit
höchsttemperaturen zwischen 15 grad im
thüringer wald im erzgebirge im vogtland
und 19 grad hier richtung münsterland
nur auf den ostfriesischen inseln und im
rheintal geht so auf 20 bis 22 grad
drauf der regen der nacht erreicht
morgen dann auch den alpenrand dahinter
gibt es kräftige schauer und im
nordosten sind auch gewitter dabei
richtung westen lockern die wolken
allerdings etwas auf dieser fleddern ein
wenig da haben sie also größere chancen
auch mal die sonne etwas länger zu sehen
der wind dazu kommt aus nördlichen
richtungen und das bleibt auch in den
nächsten tagen so und deswegen geht es
sehr wechselhaft und recht kühl weiter
mit temperaturen von 13 bis 20 grad
guten abend